foreign
so
um while Jeff's walking up actually let
me just ask how many people took Jeff
feffer's Paz to power class
oh nice okay that's a lot of Jeff you
got a lot of fans here I hope
I have a seat so um so let me introduce
Jeff for those of you who everyone knows
Jeff but let me introduce him for the
people who might not know him so Jeff um
is the uh the Thomas D Professor uh at
the GSB he is um he's been on the GSB
fact should I say it or is that okay
yeah he's better than just be fabulous
in 1979. he is uh he's taught
um I I was trying to calculate it this
morning he he's I think he's taught
about 4 000 uh students in the mbn MSX
programs in the past power class that
was my calculation and he's taught
probably and he's also got an online
version that he teaches in our Stanford
lead program
and uh I think he's probably doubled it
online as my guest so he's taught a lot
of people he's had
um tremendous influence uh in his
thinking about organizational behavior
and
um he on on Tuesday night Jeff
received the the highest the internal
award we give to faculty the Davis award
and we gave Jeff the the Davis award and
one of his colleagues described Jeff as
being both an icon in an iconoclast
icon in the sense of he's a giant as a
teacher and a thinker in in
organizational behavior and I kind of
classed it well you're going to see when
we have this discussion he thinks
differently and and great with Jeff
thank you for doing this thank you
thank you pleasure to be with you
and consistent with my past the power
principles you're my favorite Dean
okay we have some prepared questions but
I'm just going to dispense with them and
uh because I know it'll be more
interesting just to chat so let's
actually let's start with power
sure so um
so one of the things that you often say
is that people are uncomfortable with
the concept of power that's been one of
your themes to explain that
so actually in 1979 Roosevelt Moss
canner who taught and still teaches at
Harvard Business School
wrote an article entitled power of
failure and management circuits and
talked about the fact that in those days
and I think it's still true you can talk
about money and you can talk about sex
and on certain TV channels that's all
they talk about but the people are
uncomfortable talking about power that
power should call power the
organization's last 30 secrets and I
believe that that is still true people
people would like to believe that the
world is a just and fair place that
people get what they deserve that
everything works out at the end what's
the line from The Best Exotic Marigold
Hotel that everything works out in the
end and if it's not if it's not worked
out it's not yet the end there's
something to that effect
um so I think power does make people
uncomfortable I don't think power is the
last 30 secret I think it's the secret
to success if the businesses you know I
say all the time Stanford Business
school's mottos change lives change
organizations change the world if change
were going to happen without
the exertion of power and influence it
would have happened already though the
if we're going to in fact change lives
change organizations and change you're
going to need power because things are
the way they are for a reason they're in
some state of equilibrium you want to
get them out of a Dis Let's get them
into disequilibrium you need influence
all right you've written a couple of
books about power and the most recent
one is the seven Laws of Power seven
rules seven rules of power
tell us what they are sure
so the seventh so I've written actually
I think now four or five depending upon
your account books about power
that goes back to 1981 when my first
book was called power and I wrote
managing with power a bunch of others
and including my favor which is
leadership BS which is why you need a
book about power but in any event the
seven rules of Power are
and I think the first rule is the first
rule for a reason the first rule of
powers get out of your own way
that we the many people are inhibited
um I think particularly for women if you
tell them they're ambitious they would
take that as a you know as likes as an
insult it's often intended as an insult
I think we are often we are reluctant
both men and women to lean into our
ambition we are reluctant to uh do what
it takes to be powerful we are
oftentimes overly concerned with being
liked my friend Gary loveman who ran
Caesars for many years has this
wonderful saying which I have on video
if you want to be like at a dog a dog
will love you unconditionally your job
as a leader is not necessarily to win a
popularity contest but to do what needs
to be done to make the organization
successful and achieve your agendas so I
think the first rule is get out of your
own way stop
another way in which people get in their
own way is that they live with some form
of imposter syndrome they believe they
don't deserve the power that they have
they know they believe leave
or they describe themselves in
self-deprecating ways and my favorite
story The Woman comes to see me
she's working at this company that has
all the eyes and she has run a market
research program and which has made the
company a lot of money and but she's one
of her peers has gone to their common
boss and said you know I want you to um
I want you to have her report to me
which is a smart move because that way
I'll be able to um
take take your credit for her work and
she sits in the room and she says what
should I do and I said William before
we're going to do anything I want to
tell you that in the 10 minutes you've
been here I've heard many times that
you're the only woman that you're the
youngest person and in this group of
peers and the boss and you're the only
person
um you're the um
you have the least seniority in the
company I said let me give you three
other descriptors
you're the most analytically skilled
you're the only one who graduated from a
prestigious Business School
and you've run the project that's made
the most money
it's up a little straighter
Taiwanese American Woman
and I said six adjectives you get to
pick which three
you want to describe yourself in ways
I'm youngest I'm only senior ways that
make you less deserving
smartest prestigious business school
most deserving get out of your own way
that's rule one rule two break the rules
break the rules
um if I put this in the context of
social change it would be immediate
John Lewis the late representative John
Lewis said get into trouble get into
good trouble
Nelson Mandela the father of South
Africa was the father of South Africa
while he was in jail Martin Luther
King's letter from a Birmingham Jail was
written while he was in at Birmingham
Jail you're going to change things the
status quo isn't going to like that you
need to be willing to break the rules
almost in strategy you know if I said to
you today I'm going to go into business
I'm going to make a computer that runs
the Microsoft
office and Microsoft systems and it's
going to be black
what's my chance of success close to
zero because of course I'm doing what
everybody else does and strategy we
understand that you redefine industries
by breaking the rules of those
Industries Southwest Southwest Airlines
with their turnaround times Whole Foods
was selling food that people want to eat
you know so it's all around breaking
rules rule three
rule three you want to act and speak
with power
confidence is often confused with
competence but you want to act like you
know what you're doing you want to act
and speak in a powerful fashion you will
and that's why my colleague and your
friend Deborah grunfeld teaches a class
called acting with power it's all about
you know I mean great leaders are great
actors
um Andy Grove the late Andy Grove of
intel was quoted in giving a talk in the
Silicon Valley of saying you know
somebody oftentimes an Intel I didn't
know what I was doing but you have to
act like you do because if you show up
you know any any startup founder would
understand if you shot out a show up and
say you know I have no idea what what
we're doing I know we've faced some
setbacks which by the way every
organization does I'm clueless you know
the customers are going to leave the
employees are going to leave the
investors are going to leave so rule
tools rule three is show up with you oh
foreign I want to stop you before you go
to a four because already I think
everyone can see why some of what you
say is controversial so like we're here
in Silicon Valley
and um you know like I'll just play
devil's advocate for a minute you've got
you know the
some people would say looking at Silicon
Valley we've got too many people who are
adhering to the fake it till you make it
and breaking the rules in building
companies
how do you respond to that
um
so I'm
it's interesting
um on Thursday I think of this coming
week we're going to have a
series that we have three of my
colleagues are going to talk about bank
failures
which is interesting because bank
failures are an example of a principle
which I think is highly underrated which
is the self-fulfilling prophecy
um I I don't understand
the failure of First Republic Bank which
for many years was by far the highest
one of the highest performing banks in
the United States Roa Ross or anything
highest level of customer satisfaction
wonderful Bank
um except
through the through with Robert Merton
the sociologist who invented the
self-fulfilling prophecy uses his
example which is Bank runs
um you know and you know the IC I see
imitative behavior all the time I wrote
a post about layoffs being imitative
Behavior so there's a self-fulfilling
prophecy to the extent that I believe
you are successful
we
everybody in this room is a beneficiary
of the self-fulfilling prophecy because
we have convinced people and I believe
it's true but we have convinced people
that Stanford is the best business
school we get the best students the best
faculty if you get the best students of
the best faculty you become the best
business school and and what and what
was it once
uh whatever a dream or a myth becomes in
fact reality if you if you believe that
first Republic is going to fail and you
pull 100 billion dollars of deposits in
one quarter out of the out of First
Republic Bank
nobody can nobody nobody can stand that
stand up to that and so First Republic
fails I by the way and to this day I'm a
customer of First Republic and I dread
Chase because you know because Chase has
perfected the art of all large Banks
which is providing no customer service
but you know it turns out it turns out
if you're a monopoly it doesn't matter
so so so I'm a huge believer in the self
in the self-fulfilling prophecy and so
yes it is the job of a
statistics 70 80 90 of new Ventures fail
if I say to you John I want you to come
into my company
you're a smart guy you have a PhD you've
been Dean at Stanford but I you know
you've decided to make a career change
you want to work for me
I'm ready I'm like give me the pitch but
by the way 90 of new companies fail I am
a new company therefore you have a 90
chair fair chance of failing would you
like to join me I don't think you're
going to join part of life is convincing
people that the impossible is in fact
possible my dear friend who we gave the
Arbuckle award to some years ago the
famous Laura esterman
who's changing medicine who's changing
breast cancer who's changing things in a
profound way she has been quoted because
she's on a video because I recorded her
that particular day she came to my class
is convincing people that what they
didn't think Could Happen could
that's how change occurs it is easy my
friend Rudy crew who also comes to my
class New York schools Chancellor
wonderful man
my job he said is convincing Urban
education in this country is a colossal
catastrophic failure probably no worse
than
um and then the city of San Francisco
where they recalled most of the school
board
my job is to convince people who have
given up
given up on children of color on
immigrant children that in fact these
children can have the same education
that we give to the children of
privilege and that they can achieve to
the same level
now by the way we haven't yet succeeded
in doing that and so to some extent Rudy
crew and Laura Esserman are telling
people things that no do not exist but
if you don't believe that they can exist
you will never try
what
we're only through rule three but you
want to go through we want to go through
the rest of the rules quickly because
I've got so many more questions sure
okay this is wonderful we're gonna talk
we'll talk for hours we'll be here till
nine
um rule four uh so rule three is uh acts
and speak with power before it's the
build a strong personal brand just as uh
just as Coca-Cola and First Republic and
Chase and everybody else Southwest
Airlines has built a brand you need to
build a brand you need to stand for
something you need to have a succinct
way of describing what you do that
integrates your life
um with what you're currently doing as
my friends from the private boys school
that I want to
many years ago will tell you I was a
troublemaker then I still am it's fine
that's my plan
um rule five is Network relentlessly
if management slash leadership is
getting things done through other people
you need to know a lot of other people
so the more people you know the more
stuff you can get done you want to
network relentlessly rule six is use
your power when I when somebody Makes
You Dean or somebody makes you CEO or
somebody makes you president or somebody
makes you school superintendent they
have expectations that you're going to
do something use that power
Jim Collins talks about getting the
right people on the bus if you look at
what
Amir Rubin did first in Stanford
Healthcare and now at one medical which
was bought by Amazon and
the earned 14 million dollars which
makes it my closest richest friend
I have closer friends I have richer
friends but if you put the two together
if you put the two together and then
multiply the two it's a mirror and he he
basically you look at Stanford
Healthcare 70 of the people three levels
down we're different after about three
years you want the right people the Jim
Collins get the right people on the bus
you want to use your power you want to
get things done nobody has put you in
this job to do nothing you need to use
your power to make things happen
and Rule seven which is probably the
most controversial rule of all
people say to me you know you told me
things to do by the way none of these
things strikes me is very controversial
I'm getting everyone away seems common
sense all this stuff seems for common
sense but at any event it's got a social
science ban as well rule seven
is that once you have power and wealth
people will forgive or forget how you
got it
and that is I think also demonstrated
every day I begin this chapter with the
example of Lindsey Graham
uh you know then Lindsey Graham was the
ultimate never Trumper and that was the
old now he's got his lips firmly affixed
to what movie won't go there
well Trump many people did not like
Donald Trump Donald Trump and many
business people did not like but Donald
Trump McDonald the day Donald Trump
became elected and then and after it was
clear that he wasn't going to quit or
you know do something or whatever that
he was actually going to be not only a
president but a President Who used his
power a lot of the Business Leaders
changed their opinion of him
um
so rule seven is you know you need to be
successful and once you're successful
you'll have more friends than you want
that's right Jeff I sometimes think of
you as like the the this is actually a
compliment
oh no compliment begins with a statement
that this is going to be a compliment
I I sometimes I sometimes think of Jeff
as the Henry Kissinger of organizational
behavior the real politic sort of uh
view of organization paper by the way
Jeff if you are still teaching when
you're 98 or 99 and like Henry Kissinger
that'll be great so we need to aim for
that uh
um let me ask you about the class so you
you your syllabus starts by saying this
class is not for everyone that's correct
tell us what you mean by that well you
know so one year I was teaching and
there were some students it turns out
there about three of them were sitting
together and they looked every every
class I would just because they were
sitting kind of right in the middle and
about the third row back and every class
they looked like they were having some
very painful medical procedure done to
them
pick your favorite one and and and and
at the end of the class it's also clear
that they did not learn anything
so you have to be you have in order to
in order to get the benefit out of past
the power
which as you know has an enormous
waiting list in order to get the benefit
out of past the power you have to be
open
it and by the way I think this is true
for any class I think this is true for
economics I mean if I came into in into
a class in the microeconomics or for
that matter macroeconomics and said you
know I find the principles that you're
teaching have horned and therefore and
therefore I won't you know engage
intellectually with them exactly think
that I don't know amen you you wouldn't
learn anything so you have to be open
you have to be open to to the experience
you have to be open to learning and and
if you are many people have gotten
enormous benefit out of the class and if
you're not it's going to be a horrible
experience and it's an elective you have
to take it you know take something
that's more to your liking whatever so
that's so that's why I put that in so to
to get people to understand you know I
mean this is this is a this class has
been taught for a long time I'm not
likely to change
um you know if you don't like me you
don't like the material don't take it
it's not a problem I'm not going to be
personally offended okay
you've taught the class for a long time
how and this group captures about half
of that period how the students changed
um
always for the better
I tell you how the classes came
um so some years ago the I had lunch
with Carol Robin
and I said to her how do I make this
class better and she said she said you
at the moment have a class in applied
social science you need a class that
deals with what the student's actually
most interested in which is of course
themselves
and so with the did you catch that this
is true you know we're all interested in
in in in ourselves and so I basically
redid the entire class I redid the cases
so that the cases we no longer have
Robert Moses or Lyndon Johnson or
readings on Robert McNamara all these
other interesting people we have
readings on we have cases on people who
are like them five to ten years out some
of them from Harvard Business Schools
some from Stanford Business School but
people who they can entrepreneurs my
friend Jason calacanus the angel
investor the king of Angel Investing
people that they can kind of see and
relate to that's the none that's the
first big change and the second big
change is I
with the school's generous support which
I thank Paul oyer for every minute and
thank you for today
we have a coaching Executive coaching
six executive coaches who work with this
class who provide an extraordinary level
of feedback on the eight self-reflective
exercises that I give the students to do
which includes build a personal brand
who do you need to network with how are
you going to meet them what are the
personal attributes that you need to
change how are you going to change them
during the 10 weeks and it is amazing to
me what you can accomplish in eight to
ten weeks with an enormous level of
feedback and whatever so the class has
changed and because I think the classes
change I think the student experience
has changed for the better I hope and
and so that's how I think things have
changed I think the other change in the
student body which I'm sure you've seen
is we live in a world of
um
of much more social Consciousness than I
think there was 20 or 30 years ago
frankly because we live in a world
that's a hell of a lot more dangerous
than it was 20 or 30 years ago 20 or 30
years ago you did not have a land war in
Europe uh 20 or 30 years ago you did not
have or if you had it it was not as
visible police
you know mass shootings all the time
police uh you know doing what they're
what they do to people of color Etc so
we it's 130 years ago you didn't have
the prospect of Donald Trump being
president again
um you know so I we we live in a much
more dangerous world and a much more
interesting and challenging world
including the change that you've
described including artificial
intelligence where the now apparently
the former head of the father of
artificial intelligence is worried that
it's going to do all this harm and
damage whatever so we live in a
dangerous and interesting challenging
world with the climate crisis School of
Environmental Studies all this stuff and
so I think the students reflect the
world that we live in in the sense that
I think they have a much higher level of
social awareness and social conscience
they also I think are more stressed and
I think that's true for the
undergraduates at Stanford as well
all right so that actually to take picks
up another topic which you've worked on
which I would love to get your you to
share with the group which is the the
issues of health health in the workplace
uh and particularly mental health so
that's been a big topic for you recently
yes maybe share a little bit about the
thinking you've done because it's been
in a way kind of an unusual topic for a
business school Professor to think about
um I guess it's unusual I
think it's you know
you know and everything I do I think
makes all perfect sense so it's not it's
not unusual for me I wrote a book in
2018 called dying for a paycheck which
is actually had influence on the Surgeon
General of the United States it's had
the influence on people actually all
over the world
and it's
it is you know the workplace according
to my colleague Stefano zinnios and Joel
go doctoral student in the school who
helped me with the research the
workplace is the fifth leading cause of
death in the United States responsible
for 120 000 excess deaths a year and by
the way my friends in human resources
when that book came out said your
numbers are way off if they're much too
low
the general consensus of the year and
you and the code this is also by the way
pre-covered where the stress has gone up
stress is not healthy if you go read the
medical literature you can find that
stress is not healthy in two ways number
one it leads to unhealthy behaviors
which has been studied for decades
smoking drinking drug abuse
um on overeating Etc anyway
stress is also unhealthy because they
have now actually mapped in a variety of
ways the effect of stress and depression
on the central nervous system which
regulates almost every chemical in your
body including hormones and and
oxycontin and
cortisol and all of these things and so
we know that the word we know that
stress is harmful we know that
depression is harmful that we know that
the workplace the workplace because of
studies the Gallup has done and
everybody else has done is a source of
stress and depression and so therefore
if you want to fix the escalating
Healthcare crisis around the world you
actually have to address the workplace
I also my favorite chapter in dying for
workplace is chapter seven which is why
people stay
in workplaces that they know are killing
them and one simple answer is a friend
of mine
said to me Jeffrey finding another job
is a job in and of itself I am so
exhausted mentally and physically that I
can't get out
it's kind of depressing anyway I don't
want to press anybody today
it's a happy weekend
but but I would point out that the one
thing you know I mean in that book I
quote of the New York Times article
where I don't know if you know this
though at that time at least the Palo
Alto Medical Foundation had a van that
went around to high-tech workplaces
because the engineers making dating apps
I guess thought that they were doing
doing work too important to go see the
doctor and in any event the guy who ran
the Palo Alto van Pam Foundation van at
that time said I've seen Engineers with
30 year old 30 year old Engineers with
50 year old bodies he said if you're a
30 year old engineer with a 50 year old
body
you're not going to get that 30 year old
body back
it is physically it's physiologically
impossible so basically I've recently
written the LinkedIn post about this
also
prevention is a hell of a lot more cost
effective and a whole lot more effective
than remediation and this is true in
health and it's true in mental health
that that if that intervening early
um I'm doing a paper now believe it or
not with the CEO of Merrell Health which
is the um they do they provide mental
health benefits and he shows a
that the programs prevent people from
going from a state of mild crisis to
deep crisis and that's I think great
because because in both for both
physical health I mean if you're
pre-diabetic it's better to not become
diabetic if you're pre if you're
pre-depression it's better to not become
depressed because once you are in a
state of acute physical Earth or our
behavioral ill health it's very hard
it's a much more expensive to reverse it
so I'm you know so this is kind of my
one of the current things I'm working on
that I work on a few other things if you
all want to read something really
excellent that Jeff wrote recently he he
has an article in McKinsey quarterly
from a couple of years ago about it's I
think it's the first article out about
workplace mental health and it's it's
and it's really a good read actually it
starts with the story of one of our
alums and lectures a fellow named Lenny
mendonca and it's um it's it's really
impactful and the the the Vivek murti
who is the Surgeon General of the United
United States whether he's an MBA even
as a Surgeon General just not a Stanford
MBA unfortunately I
um he's he really picked up on that what
Jeff has done and now has been has been
doing a lot of mental health stuff Jeff
let me ask a question about
um that'll be relevant for this audience
so in the in your class
um you spent a lot of time the students
spend a lot of time thinking about
individually what will be their path to
power correct and um and I always tell
you that how much how much I enjoy when
someone comes to visit me and says let
me tell you how things have worked out
either in accordance or not in
accordance with my plan in Jeff's class
often it's in accordance actually which
is great
um uh so now you've got a group in front
of you they're they're one year at or
five years out or ten years that or 20
years out and what would you tell them
about their path to power starting here
that's a great question so I often will
get comments
um sometimes from people I'm connected
to on LinkedIn or other people and they
say to me I wish I'd known this 10 or 20
years ago
30 years ago you know it's like too late
for me or whatever and I tell them it's
never too late it is never too late it
is never too late to master the rules of
power it is never too late to start
doing it and so that would be my word of
advice you don't have to do it you know
it's nice if you started you know
in the womb or whenever some of these
people the Lyndon Johnson that was I
think a natural politician you know we
started it early but you don't have to
start it early it is never too late you
all have particularly you know since
everybody in this room is younger than
me
um you all have a a lot of your life
left in front of you and you can and you
can always learn things
by the way not just power things but
other things as well that that you can
use I suspect you would tell people that
is never too too too late to learn
principles of economics and my
colleagues in finance would tell you
it's never too late to learn the
principles of finance and an operations
management etc etc because you have time
left in front of you in which you can
take this learning and apply it to all
the various aspects of your life so that
would be my go go learn it today I think
the bookstore is supposed to be selling
copies that bookstore typically has
three copies of my book so they made
that now stock more but I doubt it
because of course Stanford bookstore is
no longer a bookstore if you haven't
visited it recently
it's a great read it's not too long the
new one so you can uh you can get
through it and uh in a in a couple of
evenings let's open it up for some
questions and uh and and see what what's
on people's minds so
um
you know feel free to ask Jeff anything
so Jeff a lot of your work in a lot of
the class is on individual power and
something that's been really interesting
over the last year to two is uh you know
the rise of like unions and bringing
back this idea of collective power so
I'm I'm curious because we also don't
really do it in the business school
curriculum either and so now you have
this crop of Business Leaders that have
zero idea on how to deal with Collective
power so curious one for your take on
what is kind of spurring the rise of
collective power into advice on you know
how leaders should think about this
thank you
interesting question so
um
there is
a lot more publicity about the rise of
unions than there is actually the rise
of unions I have um I was no notorious
for when I taught the class here on
human resources which I used to do which
at one point was a core class actually
having a session on unions which made me
I think relatively unique unions are
largely disappeared from all business
school curricula mostly because students
would ask me why did they need to know
about unions and I would tell them that
they weren't always going to work just
in the United States and that there were
other countries such as Germany which
has code determination and Singapore
which actually has a reasonably strong
union movement but ever so there are yes
there's a lot of publicity about the
unions that have organized in Amazon and
Starbucks that they've tried to organize
they have but the but the percentage of
people or in unions is continued
unfortunately to decline
and I
in a moment of of course things of or
give my poor Dean heartburn Stanford as
you know is facing a union organizing
campaign and I would urge you to follow
Stanford's response and watch what they
do
and watch what they do
when the clerks when the clerical
workers tried to organize a union that
many decades ago Stanford hired little
Mendelson and festive which is known as
a union busting firm The Graduate
students are now thinking about
unionizing at Stanford and The Graduate
students have asked the administration
to recognize the union without an
election you can picture what the
response would be and we will see what
Stanford does my forecast is it will not
be
it will not be nice because because it
because like all one of the things that
we have there is a
ah
Krueger and Dunning wrote this wonderful
fabulous article called unskilled and
unaware of it
most people believe that they are and
most certainly most leaders believe that
they are smart and they've gotten to
where they are because they're smart and
that therefore they know better than
everybody else and I can guarantee you
and this is not a shocking statement
that the people who run Stanford
University believe that they know better
for The Graduate for what's good for The
Graduate students and The Graduate
students do and that would be true for
all of you that if I ask you you know to
to prescribe for me or for John or for
anybody in this room what they should do
you would immediately respond to that
because you're smart talented people and
so we're going to we will be smart
Talent people we're going to tell The
Graduate students what we think they
need which is by the way not a union so
watch carefully watch the Stanford daily
it's interesting I get a daily Stanford
daily daily feed it's great so I so
that's a long way of saying that
Collective power I think is important
but it is hard to organize by the way
the decline in unions has occurred
worldwide not just in the United States
because
we've diffused our ideas around the
world and you know and so you know now
we've got this interesting issue but I
have the wonderful thing about my job
and being who I am is it the most
interesting human beings in the world
reach out to me I have personal friends
with the former head of the service
employees in the National Union the
woman who organized with her partner the
the recall of the San Francisco San
Francisco School Board reach out to me
over last Christmas
shooting in the Marjorie in the Parkland
schools
one of the least student leaders reached
out said you know about power tell me
what to do and I said
on the day a politician loses their
election because they did not support
reasonable gun regulations things will
change and until then nothing will
change not the not the moving speeches
or anything else and so you know I
we did Collective power
we need to we need to the hard work
let me add just to add a couple of
things to build on what you said Jeff
one is you know you there's a if you
read the media you hear a lot about how
everybody on a campus thinks the same
way that there's this sort of
homogeneity that has crept into to
Universal thinking let me just tell you
that among the GSB faculty
that is definitely not the case
similarly with willing to speak up and
just two more things I'll just add the
the actually the the I I actually I do
encourage you to follow the unionization
uh issue it's a it's quite interesting
the
um
many years ago many public universities
The Graduate students unionized as
employees
and um it never happened at private
institutions because
um the National Labor Relations Board
had not had not decided whether grad
students were employees or students
under the National Labor Relations Act
and about two years ago when the buyers
fishing came in they uh the rules they
changed the rules and and and made it
clear that they would recognize unions
at private institutions uh and pretty
much all of our peer institutions have
the grad students have have unionized
at Stanford it's it it it's it's not
necessarily MBA professional students
I'm sorry MBA students it's people who
do work for the for the for the
University as research assistants and
Tas but that there is a drive now to
unionize uh at Stanford and they'll
they're likely to have an election this
quarter actually and that will be uh
um interesting an uncertain change it
has two new a phenomenon to see sort of
what that would bring but that's that is
a ongoing thing right now at Stanford so
it's an interesting thing to keep in
mind by the way on unions it is true
that we do not have a class on unions
but we at least did have a big event on
unions earlier this this year as part of
the corporations and Society initiative
and it was quite a robust discussion and
um we're talking about it's it's you
know particularly if manufacturing comes
back to the U.S and look depending on
where it locates it's entirely possible
that there will be a significant
comeback of unions and that'll be an
important thing to cover in um in an in
an HR class and in in economics classes
so it's it's a it actually it is a very
interesting question all right who's got
the next question
professor pfeffer your your Rea your
comments resonate with me as much now as
they did 10 years ago
um but I want to repeat a question the
first question that I asked you in your
class because it's been 10 years that
I'm still trying to reconcile it I think
in today's world uh kindness is often
mistaken for weakness
is there a place in our world for
leaders who want to act with power but
choose to not be toxic choose to be kind
or are they not reconcilable
I don't know
you can be um
some of my favorite leaders I think
combine both you can be it's first first
of all I've a lot depends upon how you
define toxic and how you define kindness
um so let me begin with an example that
will sing far field
some years ago one of my alums from the
class of 2005
who lives in San Francisco
said I live in an expensive house which
is two blocks from a playground that I
will not permit my children to go to
do you have any ideas and I said I have
no ideas but I know somebody who runs
project open hand
project openhand began as feeding
gay men dying of AIDS in the 1980s but
has since expanded to feed homeless
people on the streets and they got a
contract from the state to feed them
actually and basically all the major
cities in California I said this is a
man used to be an investment banker
and you'll see where the story is going
to manage used to be an investment
banker decided he'd made enough money
and wanted to do something more socially
conscious and came out and is now
running project open and I said well I
can introduce you to him you have a
dinner and he will tell you about
homelessness and the crisis on the
Streets of San Francisco which bison
basically by the way are killing the
city
so he came and I he said I know what I
he said he said the city of San
Francisco believes
that it is kind
to let people live and die on the street
this is a very devout Catholic man he
said I is a devout Catholic believe that
the people on the street are children of
God and if they cannot care for
themselves the most compassionate thing
to do is to care for them even if they
do not want the care
this is a long way of saying that what
is kindness
depends upon a frame of reference is it
kind to let people live defecate die on
the street or would you do what this guy
really wants the city of San Francisco
to do which is to take people who
clearly are not able
to care for themselves and involuntarily
let me emphasize that word involuntarily
put them in single room occupancy houses
or in other kinds of housing assigned to
them a caregiver ensure that they get
their medicine ensure that they get
their food ensure that they do not wind
up at a hundred thousand dollars a day
at San Francisco General Hospital
kindness is an interesting word is it
kind for me
I was on the board of a company and we
were going to fire somebody and my CEO
said is this a kind thing to do I said
it depends
do you believe this person knows that
they are failing in their job and he
looked at me and he said yes I said is
it kind to keep someone in a job where
they are on a daily basis reminded of
their inadequacies I don't necessarily
think so I joke in my class and one of
the reasons I don't play for the
National Basketball Association is I
would not want to be reminded on a daily
basis of how incompetent I am
it is not kind and so kindness is that
this isn't this is an interesting
concept is it Kai so it's an interesting
issue around trade-offs there is a thing
that we teach in our ethics class about
you know the streetcar thing and you
know would you kill one person to save
the lives of hundreds by the way this is
not a hypothetical question almost every
new drug and every new medical procedure
begins at a high level of
ineffectiveness if you look
at the history of hard bypass operations
which is by the way why I'm sitting here
today because I was bypassed at the age
of 47. the original mortality rate for
heart bypass was 25 30 percent and it is
now like less than one percent
so as we learn new things it's things
don't always work air of travel used to
be whatever should we have prevented air
travel because some people died as we
evolved the safety protocols and Etc so
this is so the question you asked I'm
sure this is not the answer that you
wanted but yeah but but the question
that you asked has profound implications
because you need to define the terms
with a great enormous level of
specificity and to think about the
various aspects of of of of of of
trade-offs
one of the trade-offs that I think many
of my students face
which goes back to somebody that you
have not yet mentioned but I thought you
were going to Machiavelli Machiavelli
said the first responsibility of a
leader is to keep your job
because on the day that you are no
longer a leader of your organization
your ability to change lives change
organizations and change the world
disappears
so
that then the gives of this a long again
long answer to an interesting but very
profound question if in order to keep
your job as a leader you have to behave
in ways that you are not comfortable
with or that
cause harm to various other people
whatever life is complicated if life
were simple this is quote my friend Gary
loveman of Caesars
if if life was simple
you could hire stupid people you would
not need an advanced education at
Stanford you would not need the fabulous
classes that we teach if if life was
simple but because life is isn't simple
you have to think I think deeply and
profoundly about the terms about the
trade-offs about the fact that you know
the economists are right there's no free
lunch
I do give people a lot to think about
there and I'm sure everyone is is doing
who's got the next question
oh my gosh we've got a lot of hands up
all right bring someone the microphone
thank you for the talk I didn't have a
chance to take your class didn't get in
um that's okay it's never too late
there's an online version it's never too
late yeah so I'm happy to do that about
today like uh 10 years after graduation
I have a like this uh scientific
question like can we measure power like
how much power does a person have like
is there a way to do it and if it is
like can you measure the Delta for the
students who took your class yes
and those who didn't and see like is
there like a difference
so the answer to the first question is
yes
um and in the answer to the second
question is I don't do it but there is a
man named Gerald Ferris
f-e-r-r-i-s who teaches at Florida State
University who has developed instruments
to to do all of this
um and has done a lot of research and
there are studies not any of them done
by me but there are studies done by
other people that have asked questions
such as does training and the ideas of
networks and the idea of structural
holes and brokerage actually improve uh
career outcomes that was the study done
by Ron Burt b-u-r-t he's used to teach
at the University of Chicago I think
he's now at um
at bocconi but he has a website that I
highly recommend you go to because he
gives away his tools for network
analysis and is very interesting guy
there have been other studies done by
Gerald Ferris and his colleagues on
um whether or not you have uh whether or
not the degree of political skill
affects Career Success some of that
research is actually summarized in seven
rules uh there are the so there are
studies and yes you can measure it
all right let's go to the next one who's
got the next question great oh you're
really really enjoying the conversation
I did have the pleasure of taking your
class 20 years ago I'm really glad that
I did uh at the same time experiences
over the last two decades I guess I've
worked with colleagues who have been
quite Machiavellian to use the word and
almost have a pathological pursuit of
their own personal power and experienced
how that can impact upon trust and
collaboration within an organization and
I'm just wondering
have there been any studies in terms of
the link between individuals pursuing
their own personal power and how that
might impact upon trust and
collaboration and and support long-term
shareholder value and and how do you
balance the trade-offs in that situation
you know do you do you become
Machiavellian as well or do you try to
uh try to change the culture of an
organization to be to be more
collaboratively
all right so that's a long and complex
question I'll try to give a relatively
simple and shorter answer number one
with my dear colleague Charles O'Reilly
we have done a bunch of research on why
machiavellians everybody hates them
though they in narcissism we hate
narcissists and we hate machiavellians
who hate Psychopaths but they actually
succeed and they succeed and they
succeed for some reasonable reasons but
in any event so we've done some research
on that which
if you're interested send me an email
and I'll send you some of those studies
um but your question I will use as an
excuse to talk about
um
which is what I do
yeah but but because your question
embedded within your question I think
and if it's not you should correct me
um which I'm sure you will is this issue
of the trade-off between the individual
and the collective
yes I thought how because because you
said because you promised the questions
macabreons are pursuing their own
individual self-interest so that was
somehow bad though self-interest is the
basis of almost all microeconomics but
in any event
um and how does that work against the
welfare of the whole
and that's a question I get asked all
the time and I urge you to read the
newspaper
or with your version of the news if you
don't actually read a physical newspaper
every day companies have taken people by
the tens and twenties of thousands and
laid them off
and laid them off
and I you know when I wrote the book
preceding this power my friend Joe
padoli when those days ran Apple
university called me down
um after he was a student he was a
teacher here then he went to Harvard and
then he was Dean at Yale anyway he calls
me
and actually work for your father he did
my father hired him yep and so Joel
calls me down to Apple University and he
says I don't like your book and I said
well that's okay
I said what don't you like about it
everybody has their own particular he
said he said your book is all about the
individual it's not about the welfare of
the collective
and I said Joel you're part of the human
resources operation at Apple he said yes
I said many many years ago
when I was a young single man I dated a
woman who worked in apple human
resources and apple was one of the first
companies that pioneered the
organizational handbook that said we do
not owe you a job for life
we owe you an interesting job to get you
ready for your next job the jobs for
life are gone that Employment Security
is gone that we are not your mother your
father or even your aunt or uncle or
brother that we basically are an
employer and this is a transaction
work for money
and we owe you nothing
and Joel looked at me and he said that's
still
what we say and it's still by the way
what every labor lawyer that I know will
tell you you know we we live in you live
in this we are in this moment in this
country
um which is um which practices at will
employment
you ought to go out and do a little
comparative study and see how many other
countries practice that will employment
essentially zero employment at will
means you'd be fired for for cause or
for no cause for no cause at all
I'm going to lay you off by the zillions
we don't have the same protections that
they have in Europe we can argue whether
that's good or bad but it's a fact
given the fact that I have now hired you
into an organization and many
organizations including by the way apple
and including probably Stanford though
not for faculty you probably have you
sign a thing that acknowledges that your
employer will and that we can fire you
for no cause at all so the the company
has hired you in telling you we owe you
nothing
few of them nothing
companies that lay people off by the
tens of thousands without any
consideration for the fact that there
are studies that demonstrate when you
lose your job involuntarily your risk of
a heart attack goes up 40 percent
I could talk about the other health
risks also we don't need to
take care of yourself
take care of yourself if you wait for
the ma for your company to take care of
you you may be waiting for a long time
and if you don't believe me go look up
the all the
um
of websites
where people are complaining about meta
now about Google
the companies that have laid people off
oftentimes not letting them say goodbye
to their colleagues
yes I have a pretty tough and not
necessarily popular view of who you owe
things to you owe things to your friends
and your family and to yourself
and to companies and there are a few and
I can name them and if you want I'll put
you in touch with their CEOs who will
treat you like a human being when you go
to work for them
but there are a lot that don't
and you want them nothing
all right who's who's next
hi professor pfeffer Katie Hayes class
of 2018. I also didn't get into your
class but my question is nobody got into
my class that's why you're all here
today I love it well I have my daughter
here today so I wanted to ask about
generational power if you're born into
an opportunity whether it's a big family
business or even just privilege and you
get to skip some of the steps in getting
power what makes someone successful when
they're handed that versus unsuccessful
yeah that's a great question a couple
years ago in the middle of covet I was
taken out to lunch by a bunch of people
of privilege and they said we and some
of them weren't in my class and I said
why aren't you in my class and they said
we don't need to be because we're going
to succeed anyway
hahaha
and what I have found recently is that
it is I am now being approached much
more so than some Years Ago by people
running programs on Dei diversity equity
and inclusion and they say you know for
for underrepresented minorities or for
people who start out with strikes
against them because of their gender or
their race or their ethnicity or their
accent or or their socioeconomic status
or for whatever reason they actually
need to know the rules way better you
know if you've if you're I have a dear
friend whose mother's maiden name was
Rockefeller who said he was born into
the privileged sperm club or something
that you know we're basically you know
it's
he didn't have to do much except to get
born in order to succeed
um you don't problem though he took the
class and did very well in it but uh but
you probably don't need all the read
seven rules and do all this stuff
because you'll succeed in any way it's
the it's the people and I've noticed
that the percentage of women and the
percentage of minorities in my class has
actually gone up over the years partly
because of the change in the in the
proportion of the school but probably
because they have figured out on the
very very first day I have a an
African-American woman in finance speak
and on the very last day I have an
and for those who don't know the
statistics of the 70 trillion dollars of
the investable assets around the world
less than two percent are managed by
women or people of color
and and so these people have succeeded
they're both women and people of color
um and so they've had to succeed Against
All Odds and they come in and the first
day to talk about
um why she took the class and what she
uses from the class and on the last day
a different woman comes in to talk about
how to take the class forward
who's next
nice to be back Dave Spencer class of O3
I actually tried to take his class twice
but they wouldn't let me so
you wrote a story that made the cover of
business week
each other sells business week
questioning the value of an MBA saying
that based on the opportunity cost and
the financial cost that it there might
be better ways to spend your two years
and so uh joys of tenure right but in
any case I'm just wondering how your
views if any have evolved on that these
well yes I did write that article which
got me into all kinds of trouble but I
write
but if I'm not getting into trouble I
don't think I'm doing my job but in any
event job uh yes the title of the
Articles and the Business Schools less
success than meets the eye and the um
uh and what I questioned which by the
way I think actually is still open to
question is not the value of attending a
business school but the value of the
education that is provided so one of the
big controversies in the GSB at the
moment is the issue of the academic
level of academic engagement I think
um so
you know
rule five of the seven rules of powers
did not work relentlessly
should you go to the business school and
meet
talented brilliant
wealthy well-born
ambitious
successful people who are going to go
out and change life change organizations
and change the world absolutely
absolutely and there's enormous value
from doing so
should you go to business school as a
way of building your personal brand
absolutely one of the phenomena that I'm
sure you have encountered
I had a student come up to me one day
and said you know I applied for these
jobs of some jobs
and then I got admitted to Stanford
and lo and behold there was a letter in
my mailbox I hadn't even started the
goddamn program and there was a letter
we used to have mailboxes but do we
still we may still I don't know now with
everything online who knows but in any
event in those days there were these
little mail slots and this was in the
old building we're very old building and
this woman said to me she said all I did
was get admitted and the same companies
that were turning me down are writing me
sight unseen and saying would you apply
for a job
so Brandon yes
that working yes
beyond that we can have it the
interesting discussion
yes there there is yes there is a
wonderful content being delivered
whether or not anybody's losing using a
God knows but um but are learning it who
knows but but there is definitely there
is definitely value from the brand I
would tell you
um you know there's a value from the
brand of being associated with the
Bohemian Grove there's a value of the
brand I I have a friend of mine
former student
went to work for Tesla
in in
purchasing which is a big job at Tesla
because Tesla buys a lot of stuff
he's going back I told him he I said you
should go back to Brazil he's a
Brazilian he's now going back to Brazil
to be head of HR for petrobras
I said how was your experience at Tesla
he said it's as bad as you hear
um or if not worse he said however I
would have never gotten the senior
executive job at Petra Ross if I had not
worked for Tesla so many people take
jobs not long ago the business school
for the resume building qualities for
the signal that it sends or late not a
lady is still alive our colleague Mike
Spencer won the Nobel Prize talks about
signaling value
my friend who I quote probably in the
business schools article Roger Martin
who was Dean of the Toronto School
said to me it was co-founder along with
Michael Porter the consulting firm
monitor said if you give me a choice of
hiring people from the Harvard Business
School admission list versus the Harvard
Business School graduation list I might
pick the admission list but but you know
we do we do Stanford Business School
does and I think you would not deny this
a fabulous job
of selecting fantastically talented
brilliant people
so given the fact that we've
so given the fact that we've done that
of course of course coming here you know
it's now signals to people that you were
selected by the most selective business
school in the world
it was fabulous
but
but by the way there's a some of some of
our incoming students and people who
think about business schools have a
actually have a misconception about
aspects of business school which you all
could help us with in fact when you talk
to protective students which is that
they they come arrive at the school
thinking that it's a there's an either
or question about are you here to meet
people or are you here to learn
something
and the truth is that those that isn't
that's not an either or question those
things in life are complementary correct
the the value of knowing people is much
higher if you actually know something
because the people
yes
and by the way the value of having a
strong personal brand is is is much
higher if you know something because
when you are visible you better perform
a hundred percent so these things are
complementary and it's actually
important to communicate that to the
students coming into the school so if
you talk to our prospective students
tell them that we want them to come into
the right mindset all right we've got
one more question and then we're gonna
wrap it up okay who's got the last
question okay it's gonna be lightning
rounds so go ahead oh last one in the
back uh hi Naomi Allen I'm a CEO of a
pediatric mental health company and I'm
almost 50 and one of my observations is
a lot of the early 20 year old and 30
year old employees in my company are
looking for very different expressions
of power than what I was trained in and
so can you just talk about are you
seeing a generational shift around once
you have power the way you express that
specifically I think they're looking for
a lot more leaning into their
development and a lot more servant
leadership
I am a huge fan
so many people think I'm schizophrenic
which I may be because I've written
books on human resource management
including competitive advantage through
people and the human equation building
profits by putting people first and then
I teach a class on power
and um and I
um
I uh maybe I am schizophrenic but I
don't think so I I think you know I
think there is a thing to do if you want
your organization to be successful which
is consistent with the human resource
books that I've written and then I think
there's a thing to do if you want to
actually rise up and I believe this is
still true for the current generation
because I look at startups that have
been founded by
relatively young people and I do not see
them operating in any differently than
than you or I would have seen in in in
our generation I see
I see I see Founders getting thrown out
I see I see internicine struggles I see
all the things that you would have seen
or that I would have seen so yes I think
there's a lot of aspiration
you know because of all the things I've
talked about and dying for a paycheck I
mean you know the we do we have not
created the world's healthiest
workplaces
um and by the way nor are they in India
or China where the level of stress and
depression is actually even higher
um so yes they I think they would like
to live a different life
but whether or not they will actualize
and actually behave differently is a
very open question
I can tell you
years ago and Moses and I am wrote a
book called the end of power and then my
friend Henry Thames who now runs
Rockefeller Center we should actually go
to New York and go to Lincoln Center
because he can get us tickets to
anything but in any event
Henry Timms wrote a book along with a
colleague called new power and new power
talks about the democratization of power
which is kind of what you're alluding to
and of course you all you need to do is
go to the Heritage Foundation or any
place that actually measure
democratization democratization is on
Retreat all around the world power is
more centralized
um
you know so I think I think it is
important to keep
separate
people's aspirations and wishes from
their behavior number one and from what
is actually going on number two so I you
know I it is possible that the new
people will lead differently which would
be wonderful it's not it's not a bet I
would make but you know who knows
anything's possible
so Jeff you know we sometimes say at the
GSB that the value of great faculty is
that they challenge people and they
change the way they think
and so Jeff that's I think he delivered
today so thank you so much for doing
that and
[Music]
thank you